what's going on everyone battlefield one
is here and after diving into the
multiplayer I'm here today to tell you
some of the must-haves things to buy
with your war bonds
kicking things off is the hell réguel
1915 factory SMG for the assault class
and it is an excellent trench clearing
weapon sporting good accuracy damage and
a sixty round magazine I found myself
using nearly all my bullets taken down
multiple foes at once this is one of a
few weapons I recommend using when
charging headfirst into enemy lines next
up is the artillery tank with the
changeable turret on top now this
feature can be found on most armored
vehicles however it serves the best here
because now you have the go-to weapon to
take down the Zeppelin behemoth and
other enemy aircraft just two of these
artillery tanks with AAA turrets on top
can destroy a Zeppelin in a matter of
minutes and keep the skies clear for
friendly aircraft make sure to ask for
squad protection since your flag can be
seen from almost anywhere on the map
making you a sitting duck for infantry
to move up on so always be within allied
controlled areas when you're firing
the m10 hunter shotgun plays just like
the name suggests with high damage and
amazing hipfire accuracy this weapon
will help you hunt down unsuspecting
enemies and closed spaces in modes such
as domination war pigeons and team
deathmatch this shotgun leads the charge
and what makes this gun even better is
that it can be bought at the assault
rank - which isn't too far away with
excellent crowd control and surprising
range this shotgun is a must-have in
your assault class loadout
now it's time for the tank hunter
loadout for the attack airplane
typically this beast of a weapon takes
two to three shots on tanks but don't
forget to drop bombs right before you
pass over a well-placed shot on a
plane's engine will at the very least
disable it light vehicles especially
infantry and horses one shot him just to
be sure and take into account the
cannons major bullet drop by gaining
much altitude and dive bombing targets
do this especially when handling
anti-air also adding much distance from
you and their flak cannon range and
always be reloading it one of the best
medic rifles and a must buy for all the
frontline life-saving medics out there
is am Andre Storm semi-automatic rifle
packin amazing power and controllable
recoil this rifle can down your foes and
two to three shots to the body by one
shot headshot adding a 10 round magazine
and a sizable ammunition to start this
rifle is a must-have for your medic wish
list this year
grenades play a big role in battlefield
one more than ever and one of my
favorites is the incinerator grenade in
CQC moments two camped out enemy foes
this grenade is perfect for crowd
control the blinding fire alone can
block and force enemies into another
path leading to either your gun sights
or your allies this grenade is just too
hot to miss out on and there you have a
ladies and gentlemen a quick look at
some of the must-have weapons to help
bring up your kill count and full
potential in battlefield one what are
some of your favorite weapons so far in
battlefield one share your comments
below and feel free to check out some of
our other battles one videos for more in
your favorite games and entertainment
keep it here on gamespot
we have lost objective bottle